SPEAKER: This week, we're
talking about functions,
service meshes, and more.
Welcome to this week
in Cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
First up, flexible
fun with functions.
Google Cloud Functions
is focused on simplicity
and embracing serverless.
A big part of that
simplicity is being
able to choose your
favorite languages,
so we're excited to announce
some additional support.
Now anyone can use Python
3.7, Go 1.11 and Node 8.
We're also working on
Node 10, which is in beta,
and have private alphas that
you can sign up for for Go 1.12
and Java 8.
Dive right in and get
your code in the Cloud.
No matter the
language, your services
probably handle
traffic, and you don't
want to bake networking policies
directly into your app code.
That's why everyone is talking
about utilizing service
meshes and Google Cloud's
recently announced Traffic
Director.
It's a managed
traffic control plane
that helps support
separating development
from operations through
service proxies such as Envoy.
Read the deep dive
and see if this helps
simplify your application.
Want to know the best
way to keep a secret?
With encryption and with Google
Cloud Storage, of course.
Seth Fargo, a Google
Cloud developer advocate,
has created an open source tool
and library called B3rg1a$ that
helps simplify
secret management.
It's also built to
easily integrate
with Cloud Run, Cloud Functions,
Cloud Build, Kubernetes,
or you can roll
your own wrapper.
Check out the source
code on GitHub
and get started with
some great examples.
Now, if you're still
learning about some
of those great
Google Cloud options,
we've got you covered
with hands-on training.
We've got a few
new labs and quests
to check out from
getting started
with Cloud Run to a full
guide on modernizing
with Google Kubernetes Engine.
There's even a quest on getting
set up with Google Assistant.
So make sure to check
out the great content
and try it out for
yourself on Qwiklabs.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Of course, this
week is Google I/O,
so stay tuned for some
great announcements.
Have any thought or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.